and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review count
ensue oh my god is a greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life there's this guy
called Breaking Malcolm's dead he's
upset because his wife was killed by a
monster fart so years later his son
grows up and starts a family with the
good acting Olsen sister know that that
one no not that one
yes the one you didn't even know existed
but the son has to go to bail out
breaking Malcolm's dad because he keeps
getting arrested he convinces his
Sundance and monster part is what
destroyed the role hold to the channel
to their old home bizarre pickup by the
Japanese police and instead of taking
this man who suspects there's a monster
to jail they take him to the monster hey
doesn't me if I keep looking for a
mountain of heroin someone will
eventually take me to it don't burst my
bubble let me treat Tony reveal that all
this time those tremors and earthquakes
were actually the Cloverfield monster
yeah I'm sure he has a confusing
Japanese name I can't pronounce that's
why I'm calling that robber film monster
so do come over a few monster gets loose
and kills breaking Malcolm's dad and the
son is like father how could this happen
you were in all the trailers it's
because they put end in front of my name
what in a monster movie any time
somebody has and in the credits it
always means they're going to die but
you're not did watch me
damn you predictable opening credits so
this scientists gather all the distant
breeki Malcolm's dad had at the old
place but they still need more
information so they asked the son dawn
of breaking Malcolm's dead do you have
any information that he said that could
help us well he does have an entire
house in Tokyo that has like newspaper
clippings and all this information
listed everywhere no no this too
specific we need a really vague short
clue well he did say the master was
talking that's it let me consult with my
other scientists through some science
jargon that you'll never understand okay
okay but humanity might have one hope
years ago a giant dinosaur who did get
the letter that he was supposed to be
extinct who stayed around they tried to
use the a-bomb to destroy him but that
only made him mad and the Japanese
scientist calls him Goethe a name so
recognizable that it will immediately
make you laugh every single time
somebody says in the movie what is the
location of Godzilla what's so funny
it's just I don't know so much for
clover
master is destroying one of the Hawaiian
Islands the one filled with kids that
just stare blankly at something with no
emotion with something big and bad is
happening monster Godzilla finally
arises from the ocean tons of people are
being drowned just from him stepping up
every footstep he takes practically
blows up something he lets out his
trademark awesome scream it cuts to the
aftermath yeah we don't see him fighting
or doing anything cool we just sort of
see the aftereffect of him fighting and
doing all the cool stuff well it's not
like that was especially important in
the Godzilla movies basically when we
see an even bigger badder Cloverfield
monster is coming in Nevada that's right
silly monsters in this movie triple the
carnage we see her going towards Reno
all the people in the casinos look
afraid and we cut to the abdomen Oh No
look at all those cool awesome
destruction D things we didn't see
happen here's five seconds of it on the
news but it's okay I'm sure they're
building up to something really really
big like GPS the movie the monster is
going here with and we should go here to
the other monster is going that way
we'll send some guys to go that way to
main character wants to go home well put
him on this mission first we're not
going anywhere until we find a Godzilla
movie so the main character tries to
fight the monster on a bridge which is
so much more interesting than seeing
them fight in a city but then the
Japanese scientist warns that you show
not to do anything you should just let
the monster fight let nature take its
course
everything will be fine you know
Godzilla just ripped up the Golden Gate
Bridge while we were evacuating a city
filled with school buses they had a
bunch of little tiny children in them
that's because you were trying to
evacuate the city if you just do nothing
everything will be fine yeah but that
City were evacuating the two monsters
are not using it as an S and destroying
every single possible building and say
as long as you don't use any man-made
weapons on him yeah because if we didn't
do that millions of people would still
be alive hey if you want to make an
omelet you're a terrible person I know
so Godzilla finally meets up with the
two Cloverfield monsters they stare each
other down getting ready to fight and
this time they don't talk to the
aftermath
they got to something totally different
people trying to figure out how to
destroy the monsters because clearly we
haven't seen enough of that yet you know
I never liked those Godzilla movies
where you see him destroying stuff
breathing fire and fighting other
monsters I always said they should so
when pan into a bunch of people talking
about how they're gonna stop the
incredible thing that's happening on
screen they shall remain this movie
people yelling at each other and
Godzilla
maybe fuck intelligence exhausted from
all the not action going on so he falls
to the ground and our main character is
like bye guys I feel so bad for a
character has gotten even less screen
time than my father
oh yeah sure you really did oh yeah I
believe it the first reboot of Godzilla
in so many years
I bet you're really dead whenever I'm
gonna do the thing all these movies do
gonna get myself in trouble with the
other monster and then you're gonna save
me at the last minute deal and I don't
give a crap so in the last few minutes
we finally get some monster fighting in
this movie I'll shout at night in the
dark with a bunch of smoke where it's
really hard to see and Godzilla does
five cool moves and then falls over dead
again
whatever I suppose it has to find so our
main characters we may with a family
consulate gets up to go into the ocean
and the headline reads Godzilla our
Savior
what of course our savior what kind of
save you wouldn't drown thousands of
people in Hawaii or kill dozens more on
the Golden Gate Bridge it's what Jesus
Silla would do so if you like Godzilla
movies with little to no Godzilla in its
then this movie is for you what do you
say Godzilla
I'll keep you up with Matthew Broderick
again this is just to eat boom see
I come on in McDowell the other come on
James come on I promise you'll see more
room in the sequel I even hear Cthulhu
have to choose I continue
you